No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs to help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没人会为了汉克的电子表格而去他的店里。他们去那里是为了吃上一顿美味的披萨。不过最近，店里变得冷清了。于是汉克决定重新推出1美元一片的披萨。他请微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，以帮助他判断自己是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及哪些小额附加项目能让1美元披萨的方案行得通。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. Is your commute the most stressful part of your day? Does your blood pressure rise when you get behind the wheel? Or do you think of your car as a welcome retreat where you can listen to your music and podcasts in peace? Many of us drive every day, but we rarely stop to think about how driving affects our moods, our emotions, and the rest of our lives.
现在，汉克的店门口排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。欲了解更多信息，请访问M365Copilot.com/work。通勤是你一天中最有压力的部分吗？当你坐到驾驶座上时，你的血压会升高吗？还是说你把车视为一个受欢迎的避风港，可以在那里安静地听音乐和播客？我们许多人每天都在开车，但很少停下来思考驾驶如何影响我们的情绪、情感以及生活的其他方面。
And conversely, how our emotions and our personality influence are driving. Today we're going to talk to a traffic psychologist about what's going on, when we get behind the wheel. Why do some people find driving more stressful than others? What causes road rage? And how can you defuse a tense traffic situation? How will driving change with the rise of more automated or even self-driving cars? And how can psychological research help make the roads a safer and more pleasant place for us all?
反之亦然，我们的情绪和个性又是如何影响我们的驾驶的。今天，我们将与一位交通心理学家探讨当我们坐到驾驶座上时会发生什么。为什么有些人觉得开车比其他人压力更大？是什么导致了路怒症？你又该如何化解紧张的交通状况？随着自动化甚至自动驾驶汽车的兴起，驾驶将如何改变？心理学研究又如何能帮助我们所有人让道路变得更安全、更舒适？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Dwight Hennessy, a professor and chair of the psychology department at Buffalo State University. His research interests include driver stress and aggression, how to encourage safe driving, and how driving stress spills over into everyday life. He's the author of numerous research papers and editor of two books,
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是布法罗州立大学心理学系教授兼系主任德怀特·亨内西博士。他的研究兴趣包括驾驶员压力与攻击性、如何鼓励安全驾驶，以及驾驶压力如何蔓延到日常生活中。他是众多研究论文的作者，并编辑了两本书，
Traffic Psychology and International Perspective, and contemporary issues in road user behavior and traffic safety. He's been interviewed about traffic and driver behavior by media outlets, including the New York Times, the CBC, and the Seattle Times. Dr. Hennessey, thank you for joining me today. Well, I'm happy to be here with you today. Let's start with a question I posed in the introduction. Is driving inherently stressful for most people?
《交通心理学与国际视角》以及《道路使用者行为与交通安全中的当代问题》。包括《纽约时报》、《加拿大广播公司》和《西雅图时报》在内的多家媒体都曾就交通和驾驶员行为采访过他。亨内西博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。很高兴今天能和您在一起。让我们从我在介绍中提出的一个问题开始。对大多数人来说，开车本身就是一种压力吗？
And if so, why is that? What makes driving stressful? Yeah, overall, I would say that, driving is stressful for just about everybody who drives in some way. It's an interesting topic because there's no shortage of stories. People are intimately involved in their commutes and it's something that impacts so much of our lives that until something happens, we often don't really stop and reflect. But the traffic environment really is full of these everyday stressors that on their own might seem mundane, but they tend to accumulate. And most people have a commute that requires them to
如果是这样，为什么会这样？是什么让驾驶变得有压力？是的，总的来说，我想说驾驶对几乎所有开车的人来说在某种程度上都是有压力的。这是一个有趣的话题，因为故事层出不穷。人们与他们的通勤生活息息相关，这是一件对我们生活影响如此之大的事情，以至于在发生什么事情之前，我们往往不会真正停下来反思。但交通环境确实充满了这些日常压力源，它们单独看起来可能很平凡，但往往会累积起来。大多数人的通勤都需要他们
spend a considerable amount of time on the road, especially in bigger cities. So the more we do this, the more it piles up. And we just have these expectations about what other people are supposed to be doing. So not only do we have stressors that come from the situation itself, but also in our transactions and interactions with other people. How do you define road, rage and how is it different from aggressive driving? Yeah, that's a that's a big question in our discipline. There's different ideas about those. Road rage is usually referred to as the major things, like the really dramatic, violent kinds of actions, whereas we tend to talk about driver aggression as maybe the more, quote, mild things that happen where, you know, road rage might be
在路上花费相当长的时间，尤其是在大城市。所以我们做得越多，压力就堆积得越多。我们对其他人应该做什么有各种期望。因此，我们不仅有来自情况本身的压力源，还有我们在与他人交易和互动时产生的压力。你如何定义路怒症，它与攻击性驾驶有何不同？是的，这是我们学科中的一个大问题。关于这些有不同的看法。路怒症通常指的是重大事件，比如那些非常戏剧性、暴力的行为，而我们倾向于将驾驶员攻击性称为可能发生的、引用“温和”的事情，你知道，路怒症可能是
something like a physical altercation where somebody gets out. They tend to be more dramatic. The outcomes tend to be more severe, whereas aggression might be seemingly more trivial, although I will argue that those seemingly trivial things often escalate and they pile up and they pile up, but, you know, honking a horn at somebody, yelling, shooting the fingers, things like that. So when I say mild, they don't necessarily mean that these are things that we shouldn't be concerned about. But I think in people's everyday conversations, that's how they differentiate. But there is a, there's also a challenge that we have in our discipline when we talk about the term, quote, aggressive driving. Because there's a big confound that happens there in everyday language
某种肢体冲突，比如有人下车。它们往往更具戏剧性。结果往往更严重，而攻击性可能看起来更琐碎，尽管我会争辩说那些看似琐碎的事情往往会升级，它们会堆积起来，但你知道，对某人按喇叭、大喊大叫、竖中指等等。所以当我说是温和的时候，并不一定意味着这些是我们不应该关注的事情。但我认为在人们的日常对话中，他们就是这样区分的。但我们学科在谈论“攻击性驾驶”这个术语时也面临一个挑战。因为在日常语言中存在一个很大的混淆，
where people include things that aggression researchers wouldn't consider as aggression. So things like speeding and weaving, those are illegal. In many cases, they are dangerous in some ways. But in a more technical sense, we don't consider them as aggressive. They're not aggression. They're not an intentionally harmful action. Where the average person then takes this into their everyday conversation, makes it challenging for us as researchers because they will
人们把攻击性研究人员不会认为是攻击性的行为也包括在内。比如超速和穿插车道，这些是违法的。在许多情况下，它们在某些方面是危险的。但在更技术的层面上，我们不认为它们是攻击性的。它们不是攻击。它们不是一种蓄意伤害的行为。而普通人在日常对话中会用到这个词，这给我们研究人员带来了挑战，因为他们会
talk about, for example, my neighbors are really aggressive driver. And what they mean is they drive fast. Whereas I'm thinking about an aggressive driver as somebody who routinely does things that is intended to harm somebody, like tailgating them or swerving in front of them and hitting their brake, like a break check, or the more violent things that you asked about in this question. So that makes it really hard for us because you try to tell people these are the things that are related to aggressive driving and what they think is speeding rather than harmful actions. But that seems like a very fine line. I mean, if somebody is, you know, riding up on my tail because I'm not going fast enough. I mean, yeah, it's aggressive. It's right on the precipice, I think, of road rage. I mean, how do you measure it if the line is blurry? And that's one of the big obstacles for us as scientists in this area. And I think that's an obstacle for all aggressive researchers to find that fine line that you're talking about and how do we identify it.
谈论，例如，“我的邻居是一个非常有攻击性的司机”。而他们的意思是他们开车很快。而我所认为的攻击性驾驶是指那些经常做出旨在伤害他人的行为的人，比如跟车太近，或者在别人面前猛打方向盘并踩刹车，就像“刹车测试”那样，或者你在这个问题中问到的更暴力的行为。所以这让我们很难办，因为你试图告诉人们这些才是与攻击性驾驶相关的事情，而他们认为的是超速，而不是伤害性行为。但这似乎是一条非常细的界限。我的意思是，如果有人，你知道，因为我开得不够快而紧跟在我的车尾。我的意思是，是的，这很有攻击性。我认为这就在路怒症的边缘。我的意思是，如果界限模糊，你如何衡量它？这也是我们该领域科学家面临的一大障碍。我认为这也是所有攻击性研究人员面临的障碍，即找到你所说的这条细微界限，以及我们如何识别它。
So if we take horn honking, for example, I think this is the prime example of it. Horn honking also has a symbolic function in many cultures. If I'm at a light and it turns green and not paying attention, somebody else, might just lightly tap the horn as a signal. Do I interpret that as aggressive? That's a different conversation, right? Oftentimes that's what happens for people, that they, as the recipient of that,
所以如果我们以按喇叭为例，我认为这是最典型的例子。在许多文化中，按喇叭也有象征功能。如果我在红绿灯前，灯变绿了而我没注意，别人可能会轻轻按一下喇叭作为信号。我把它解读为攻击性吗？那是另一回事了，对吧？通常情况下，对于作为接收者的人来说，
see that as something malicious. But as a scientist, can we differentiate when it's a small tap versus when it's a long leaning on the horn or a frequent engagement of that horn? So it's hard. in the bigger picture to find where that dividing line is for you that might be different than that dividing line that's for me. I think there's a stereotype that men tend to be more aggressive drivers and possibly engage more in road rage than women. Is that borne out by the research?
会认为那是恶意的。但作为科学家，我们能否区分什么是轻按，什么是长时间按喇叭或频繁使用喇叭？所以很难。从大局来看，找到那条分界线对你来说可能与对我来说不同。我认为有一种刻板印象，即男性往往比女性更有攻击性，并且可能比女性更多地参与路怒症。研究证实了这一点吗？
For the most part, yeah, I think that especially when you get into the more extreme acts of aggression and violence. But I will say that over the years that I've been doing this, that gap has narrowed considerably. And I think we do have to watch out for the same stereotypes that exist in our culture about aggression in general, that there's a myth that women are unaggressive or less aggressive in some ways. But when you look at different versions of aggression, just in general, you'll find that there are some areas where women are more aggressive than men, relational aggression, for example, or as aggressive as men in, say, verbal types of things. And something similar emerges in the traffic environment as well. It depends on a lot of
在很大程度上，是的，我认为尤其是当你进入更极端的攻击和暴力行为时。但我不得不说，在我从事这项工作的这些年里，这种差距已经大大缩小了。我认为我们确实必须警惕我们文化中关于攻击性的一般刻板印象，即存在一种神话，认为女性在某些方面是不具攻击性或攻击性较弱的。但当你观察不同版本的攻击性时，你会发现有些领域女性比男性更具攻击性，例如关系攻击，或者在言语类型的事情上与男性一样具有攻击性。交通环境中也出现了类似的情况。这取决于很多
different factors, but there are times where there are women who are just as, if not more aggressive than men. Well, I understand that you have found differences between men and women and how they extend their personal space when they're driving. Could you explain what you found in that arena? Yeah, personal space is a, that's another one of these tough topics because by its very nature, it's invisible and how do you identify it? And so one of the things we've tried to do is rather than find an actual boundary that exists, we've tried to really tap into the subjective nature of that and ask people about their preference for it. And one of the things about personal space is, one of its functions is protective. And in some ways we've found over the years and other people,
不同的因素，但有时女性的攻击性与男性一样，甚至比男性更强。嗯，我了解到你发现了男性和女性在开车时如何扩展个人空间方面的差异。你能解释一下你在那个领域发现了什么吗？是的，个人空间是另一个棘手的话题，因为就其本质而言，它是无形的，你如何识别它？所以我们尝试做的一件事是，与其寻找一个实际存在的边界，我们试图真正挖掘其主观性，并询问人们对它的偏好。关于个人空间的一点是，它的功能之一是保护性的。在某种程度上，我们多年来发现，其他人
I think, have borne this out that for whatever reason, men tend to be more defensive of that space, more defensive of the vehicle. Some people have argued that maybe, there's more of an investment personally in mask quote masculinity and ownership of vehicles and and and and and and that type of concept again I think a lot of that gap is narrowing um men tend to drive more than women do as well so that exaggerates the the the thought and the feeling about the defensiveness and and this I mean that's part of safety right when you drive more there's just a greater level of risk over time and and I don't I don't think It's an enormous difference.
我想，也证实了这一点，即无论出于什么原因，男性往往更倾向于捍卫那个空间，更倾向于捍卫车辆。有些人认为，也许，在所谓的“男子气概”和车辆所有权以及那种类型的概念上投入了更多的个人情感，同样，我认为这种差距正在缩小。男性开车也比女性多，所以这夸大了对防御性的想法和感觉，我的意思是，这本身就是安全的一部分，对吧？当你开车更多时，随着时间的推移，风险水平就会更高，而且我不认为这是一个巨大的差异。
So, again, these are all on average. And this is a point I try to make routinely when I talk in my courses. Remember, we talk about differences that we're talking on average. There are some women that are very defensive of space and some men that are not defensive of space at all. What's the impact, if any, of the type of car that a person is driving? I know there's stereotype that if you happen to have a red sports car that the cops are going to pull you over more often for speeding and what, you know, they call some
所以，这些都是平均水平。这是我在课程中经常强调的一点。记住，我们谈论的是平均差异。有些女性对空间非常防御，而有些男性则根本不防御空间。一个人驾驶的汽车类型有什么影响吗？我知道有一种刻板印象，如果你碰巧有一辆红色跑车，警察会因为超速更频繁地把你拦下来，还有，你知道，他们称某些
cars, muscle cars, which sort of gives you the impression that, you know, there's something very aggressive going on in that vehicle. Is there any truth to that sense? I mean, I've heard those things over the years. I don't think there's a lot of evidence that bears witness to, like, a red car, for example, as you say, other than could a red car be more easily detected at certain times? Maybe. I've heard that suggestion. But again, I don't know if there's a lot of data to match that. But I will say that when you talk about things like getting tickets and getting pulled over, et cetera, like any area of police sciences, are there times when police may have stereotypes? And you use the term muscle car. Are there some cars or there's some vehicles that
车为“肌肉车”，这让你觉得，你知道，那辆车里正在发生一些非常有攻击性的事情。这种感觉有道理吗？我的意思是，多年来我听说过这些事情。我不认为有很多证据能证明，比如你说的红色汽车，除非红色汽车在某些时候更容易被发现？也许吧。我听说过这种建议。但同样，我不知道是否有大量数据能匹配这一点。但我确实想说，当你谈论像收到罚单和被拦下之类的事情时，就像警察科学的任何领域一样，警察有时会有刻板印象吗？你用了“肌肉车”这个词。有没有一些车或者有些车辆
maybe are more easily identified or maybe more stereotypically associated with driving fast? probably and there are certain vehicles that maybe certain individuals might be more inclined to gravitate towards but does that mean that they always drive faster? Does that mean that they're always going to be centered out? Possibly not. But and I think that starts to get into that bigger picture idea that we talk about of this interaction between the individual who they are in general and who. who they become in the traffic environment.
也许更容易被识别，或者可能在刻板印象中与开快车联系在一起？可能有，而且确实有些车辆可能是某些人更倾向于选择的，但这是否意味着他们总是开得更快？这是否意味着他们总是会被挑出来？可能不是。但我认为这开始触及我们谈论的那个大局观念，即个体本身是谁，以及他们在交通环境中变成了谁之间的互动。
So, there are two different concepts, but, you know, they interact very well that the way people are in life does translate to who they are when they drive, not exclusively. So is a certain type of person more likely to gravitate towards a faster car, a bigger car, a more powerful car? Yeah. Does that mean that they drive that way? In some ways, yes. Now, I'm originally from New York, and I still drive when I go there. And my sense is that New Yorkers, at least those who live in New York City, are more aggressive than the people I generally drive around in the D.C. area. And it's also my impression that drivers in Boston are less inclined to follow the rules. Like, they don't stop at stop signs. They don't care about the lanes in the road. And I'm just wondering whether my impressions are borne out by data or if I'm just like really
所以，这是两个不同的概念，但是，你知道，它们互动得很好，人们在生活中的方式确实会转化为他们开车时的样子，虽然不是全部。那么，某种类型的人是否更有可能倾向于选择更快的车、更大的车、动力更强的车？是的。这是否意味着他们就是那样开车的？在某些方面，是的。现在，我来自纽约，我去那里时仍然开车。我的感觉是，纽约人，至少是那些住在纽约市的人，比我在华盛顿特区周围开车时遇到的人更有攻击性。而且我的印象是，波士顿的司机更不倾向于遵守规则。比如，他们不在停车标志前停车。他们不在乎路上的车道。我只是想知道我的印象是否被数据证实，或者我是否真的
have these stereotypes in my brain are, but are drivers in some geographic locations more or less aggressive or more or less likely to adhere to the traffic laws? As a simple general statement, yes, I think there is something to that. It's part of understanding the culture and subculture of driving. So in some ways, we have traffic laws and those traffic laws, I mean, there are some of them that are pretty much standard wherever you go. But people also tend to develop their own unwritten rules depending on where they are. Because in some ways, and even when you think about how teenagers learn to drive, in many ways, they've been learning to drive for a long time. So my kids learned how to drive from me sitting in the back when they
大脑中有这些刻板印象，但在某些地理位置的司机是否更有攻击性或更少攻击性，或者更有可能或更不可能遵守交通法规？作为一个简单的概括性陈述，是的，我认为这其中是有道理的。这是理解驾驶文化和亚文化的一部分。所以在某些方面，我们有交通法规，这些交通法规，我的意思是，其中一些无论你去哪里基本上都是标准的。但人们也倾向于根据他们所在的地方发展出自己的不成文规则。因为在某些方面，甚至当你想到青少年如何学习开车时，在很多方面，他们已经学习开车很长时间了。所以我的孩子们是在我坐在后面时学会开车的，当他们
were young. And so they picked up on my habits. They picked up on the way I deal with particular situations. It's no different than any other avenue of life in parenting. Well, the same thing happens when you're driving in a particular area. You kind of learn those things that are acceptable and unacceptable in that particular area. And this is actually one of the things that drew me into this sub-discipline. I'd never heard of it before, but as a social and environmental psychologist, I'm keenly interested in social factors on how we share those with each other. And so I moved from a fairly small city growing up, and I moved to graduate school in a large city. And I was taken by how I changed as a driver in very short order. My patterns of driving changed, my thoughts about
还小的时候。所以他们学会了我的习惯。他们学会了我处理特定情况的方式。这与育儿生活中的任何其他方面没有什么不同。嗯，当你在一个特定的区域开车时，同样的事情也会发生。你会在那个特定的区域学到什么是可以接受的，什么是不可接受的。这实际上是我被这个子学科吸引的原因之一。我以前从未听说过它，但作为一名社会和环境心理学家，我非常关注社会因素以及我们如何与彼此分享这些因素。所以我从一个相当小的城市长大，搬到了一个大城市读研究生。我被我在短时间内作为一名司机的变化所震撼。我的驾驶模式改变了，我对
driving changed, and I became in some ways more, quote, aggressive, more assertive because I had to be. because my very first day, the light turned yellow, and I was looking to turn, and I stopped, and I had vehicles behind me leaning on their horn, like, visibly angry with me because I come to learn very, very quickly after that, that when the light turned red, multiple vehicles still go through, and I wasn't accustomed to that. And so if I was going to, quote, survive in that driving environment, I had to adapt and I had to adjust to those unwritten rules of the road. How do we learn that? There's no book.
驾驶的想法也改变了，我在某种程度上变得更“有攻击性”，更果断，因为我必须这样。因为我第一天，灯变黄了，我正准备转弯，我停了下来，我后面的车辆在按喇叭，就像，明显对我很生气，因为我之后很快就了解到，当灯变红时，多辆车仍然会通过，而我不习惯那样。所以如果我要在那种驾驶环境中“生存”下去，我就必须适应并调整到那些道路的不成文规则。我们如何学习这一点？没有书。
I didn't show up in this city first day and it's like, all right, here's your driving manual for driving in this city. I had to learn it firsthand. And so we share the culture of driving in those particular areas. So does that mean that people in urban areas may be more aggressive drivers because you have to be to survive? In some ways that that is possible. although I've been in some rural areas where people in different ways drive in a very assertive way. I've been on long stretches of rural road. In fact, I just witnessed, I experienced this fairly recently in another country where I'm driving on a rural road and a vehicle comes up just flying behind me.
我第一天到这个城市时，没有人给我一本手册说：“好吧，这是你在本市开车的驾驶手册。”我必须亲身学习。所以我们分享了在这些特定区域的驾驶文化。那么这是否意味着城市地区的人可能是更有攻击性的司机，因为你必须这样才能生存？在某种程度上，这是可能的。尽管我也去过一些农村地区，那里的人以不同的方式以非常果断的方式开车。我走过很长的乡村道路。事实上，我最近在另一个国家亲眼目睹、经历过这一点，我在乡村道路上开车，一辆车在我后面飞驰而来。
And I hadn't really learned, I guess, those unwritten rules of the road where I was driving a little over the speed limit to that. I was driving a little bit over the speed limit. They were driving a lot over the speed limit and they just blew past me. So, you know, I could take offense to that. But I just took that as, all right, that's what they do here. So it happens in all environments, but I think your assessment is fairly accurate that in that environment where there's more vehicles and there's there's more interaction. You have to learn that pretty quickly and you have to adjust. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill,
而我并没有真正学会，我想，那些道路的不成文规则，我当时开得比限速稍微快一点。我开得比限速稍微快一点。他们开得比限速快得多，他们直接从我身边呼啸而过。所以，你知道，我可以对此感到冒犯。但我只是把它当作，“好吧，这就是他们在这里做的事情。”所以这种情况在所有环境中都会发生，但我认为你的评估相当准确，即在车辆更多、互动更多的环境中。你必须很快学会这一点，并且你必须调整。你的夏天现在就开始了，在家得宝（The Home Depot）享受阵亡将士纪念日的优惠。是时候用下一款烤架来开启夏季烧烤了，
four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, pricing invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Let's talk a little bit about driver behavior.
四头燃气烤架，特价仅需199美元。整个季节都可以用汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）West Grove七件套户外餐桌椅来招待客人，仅需49美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为5月14日至5月27日。仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅HomeDepot.com/price-match。让我们谈谈驾驶员行为。
Now, I used to live on a suburban street in northern Virginia where people drove too fast. And we did tests and some of us started a campaign to get the State Department of Transportation, which managed the roads there to implement measures to slow people down. And they started this whole battle in the neighborhood of speed humps or speed bumps, which are not the same thing I learned. Other people wanted flashing signs telling you. you, what your speed was as you drove past. And ultimately, all the state did was paint some new lines that made it look as though the road was narrower than it actually was, which didn't
现在，我曾经住在北弗吉尼亚州的一条郊区街道上，那里的人开车太快了。我们进行了测试，我们中的一些人发起了一项运动，要求管理那里道路的州交通部采取措施让人们慢下来。他们在社区里开始了关于减速带或减速丘的整场战斗，我了解到它们不是一回事。其他人想要闪烁的标志，告诉你当你开车经过时你的速度是多少。最终，州政府所做的只是画了一些新的线条，使道路看起来比实际更窄，这并没有
really have any impact at all. So I'm wondering, what are proven methods that can slow people down? Yeah, there are definitely calming, traffic calming measures that do work. It's just they don't work for everybody. So the signs that have the speed on them. Well, you hear anecdotal stories of people who are like, oh, I'm going to see how fast I'm going, right? Let's see if I can break my record or something like that. Or there are people who will drive over speed bumps or speed humps at the same speed. They just don't really care about their vehicle. But I think for the most part, and this is just my general take over the years, I think most people want to drive safely. We develop bad habits sometimes. And again, where we're driving like other people do in that particular location or
真正产生任何影响。所以我很好奇，有什么行之有效的方法可以让人慢下来？是的，肯定有交通稳静化措施是有效的。只是它们并不对每个人都有效。所以那些显示速度的标志。嗯，你会听到轶事，有人说：“哦，我要看看我开得有多快，对吧？看看我能不能打破我的记录之类的。”或者有些人会以同样的速度开过减速带或减速丘。他们只是不太关心他们的车辆。但我认为在大多数情况下，这是我多年来的总体看法，我认为大多数人想安全驾驶。我们有时会养成坏习惯。同样，我们在开车时就像那个特定地点的其他人一样，或者
for me, what we found, one of the biggest things that contributes to driver stress and driver anger and driver regression is time urgency. And I think that is another thing that leads to increased unsafe driving, that we're just in a hurry. We've got to get somewhere 10, minutes ago. And so we push those boundaries of safety. And there's an acceptable level of risk that we're willing to take all of us. Like just like let's put the cards on the table about this. Driving is not safe. It's dangerous. We dichotomize safety. It makes us feel better to think about things as being safe. So I wear my safety belt. I've got all these airbags so I'm safe. But you're not. Bad things can still happen to you. But we don't, we don't, we don't.
对我来说，我们发现，导致驾驶员压力、驾驶员愤怒和驾驶员攻击性的最大因素之一是时间紧迫感。我认为这是导致不安全驾驶增加的另一件事，我们只是很匆忙。我们必须在10分钟前到达某个地方。所以我们突破了安全的界限。我们愿意承担一个可接受的风险水平，我们所有人都是如此。就像，让我们把牌摊开来说吧。开车是不安全的。它是危险的。我们将安全二分法。认为事情是安全的让我们感觉更好。所以我系好安全带。我有所有这些安全气囊，所以我很安全。但你不是。坏事仍然可能发生在你身上。但我们不，我们不，我们不，
like to think about that attitudinally because it makes us uncomfortable. But what happens sometimes is when we think about something as being safe now that we have all these safety features, we start to take fewer precautions. But what we really should be talking about is what are the things that make it safeer? That's what traffic safety people are doing. They're trying to make it as safe as possible while still understanding that it's an unsafe environment. and it's an unsafe action. So I think in some ways, we've got some of these measures, like speed pumps really do work.
喜欢从态度上考虑这一点，因为它让我们感到不舒服。但有时发生的情况是，当我们认为某件事是安全的，因为我们现在拥有所有这些安全功能时，我们开始采取更少的预防措施。但我们真正应该谈论的是什么让它更安全？这就是交通安全人员正在做的事情。他们试图在理解它是一个不安全的环境和不安全的行为的同时，尽可能地让它变得安全。所以我认为在某些方面，我们有一些这样的措施，比如减速丘确实有效。
Sometimes the reflectors or the little, you know, the bumps in the road to kind of tell you you're veering off the lanes. Those kinds of things work for the average person who really wants to tame down their safety. We talk about three E's in traffic research. There's enforcement. That gets people to slow down. put a cop on the side of the road, put up speed cameras and stuff like that, although people adapt to them,
有时反光镜或路上的小凸起，可以告诉你你正在偏离车道。这些东西对那些真正想控制自己安全的人来说是有效的。我们在交通研究中谈论三个“E”。一个是执法（Enforcement）。这能让人们慢下来。在路边放一个警察，安装测速摄像头之类的，尽管人们会适应它们，
people adjust to them, people share information about where you can find them. So enforcement can work, although it doesn't always work. One of the things that comes up about speeding is sometimes people who make more money than the average person, maybe a speeding ticket's not that big of a deal for them. Some countries have gone to a floating system where you pay a proportion or you pay a higher level if you make more money so that it cuts into your pocket a little bit more. So there's enforcement. There's engineering, which is kind of what we're talking about. Can you make the road safer? Can you put these things in place? Like roundabouts. Roundabouts really, once you get used to them, some people have a hard time figuring them out at first. But once you've got them down,
人们会调整，人们会分享关于你在哪里可以找到它们的信息。所以执法可以奏效，尽管它并不总是奏效。关于超速，出现的一件事是，有时收入高于平均水平的人，也许超速罚单对他们来说不是什么大不了的事。一些国家已经转向浮动系统，如果你赚的钱更多，你支付的比例或水平就更高，这样它就会对你的口袋造成一点影响。所以有执法。有工程（Engineering），这正是我们正在谈论的。你能让道路更安全吗？你能把这些东西安装到位吗？比如环岛。环岛确实，一旦你习惯了它们，有些人起初很难弄清楚它们。但一旦你掌握了它们，
they really can calm traffic. So can we engineer it? Yes, we can. But education is also part of it. And that's a big hurdle. How do you convince somebody to drive more safely when they've already convinced themselves that they are already driving safely? That's hard to do.
它们确实可以平息交通。所以我们能通过工程手段实现吗？是的，我们可以。但教育（Education）也是其中的一部分。这是一个巨大的障碍。当一个人已经说服自己他们已经在安全驾驶时，你如何说服他们更安全地驾驶？这很难做到。
But those three together, I think, are a good approach to helping to increase the safety or make it safer. So you mentioned a lot of the automated features that are in cars. today. And we haven't even talked about, say, backup cameras or the warning signals when you're leaving your lane and so forth. Does this make people better drivers or do they become more complacent? Yeah, I think it depends on what you mean by better. Because there are some theories out there borne out by data that when you add more safety features, sometimes people then start to take more risk because they shift that boundary at which they now feel they really should take
但这三者结合在一起，我认为是帮助提高安全性或使其更安全的一个好方法。所以你提到了汽车中许多自动化的功能。今天。我们甚至还没有谈到，比如倒车摄像头或当你离开车道时的警告信号等等。这会让人们成为更好的司机，还是他们变得更加自满？是的，我认为这取决于你所说的“更好”是什么意思。因为有一些理论被数据证实，当你增加更多的安全功能时，有时人们就开始承担更多的风险，因为他们改变了那个他们现在觉得真的应该采取
precautions. But are they beneficial to have those kinds of features? Absolutely. So I'm never, so please, nobody interpret me saying that these are bad, that we have these safety features. But can people start to lose concentration a little bit more because they rely on the technology to quote save them, perhaps. But I know I will admit to being guilty of this that, I mean, see, nobody can keep a perfect path and track while they're driving. Have my features told me, hey, wait a second. Look out.
预防措施的界限。但拥有这些功能有益吗？绝对有。所以，我从来没有，所以请不要有人解释说我说这些是不好的，我们有这些安全功能。但人们是否会因为依赖技术来“拯救”他们而开始失去一点注意力，也许吧。但我知道我会承认自己有罪，我的意思是，看，没有人能在开车时保持完美的路径和轨迹。我的功能告诉过我，“嘿，等一下。小心。”
Absolutely. And I thank my safety features profusely for that. I mean, so they are wonderful. But could it lead somebody to the point where they're not. paying attention as much as they possibly should because, and I won't say which person in my family is guilty of this, but can you hit something backing up with a backup camera? Yes. So it's, yeah, they're not foolproof, right? I've done it. Yeah. The number one safety feature is still that driver, not the vehicle itself. It's the driver and the vehicle together that is going to
绝对有。我非常感谢我的安全功能。我的意思是，所以它们很棒。但这是否会导致某人达到他们没有像他们应该的那样关注的程度，因为，我不会说我家里哪个人有罪，但你能用倒车摄像头撞到东西吗？是的。所以，是的，它们不是万无一失的，对吧？我做过。是的。第一大安全功能仍然是那个驾驶员，而不是车辆本身。是驾驶员和车辆在一起，这将
make this safer. What about self-driving cars? I mean, how do you develop a self-driving car where people will sit there and kind of give up control or do they have to have a little bit of control to feel comfortable? And how does the car make decisions around whether, you know, do I hit that abutment or do I run into that child? Yeah, that is a hot topic in the area of autonomous vehicles. And I personally don't do research on that. I know people who do. There's a huge ethical consideration in that area, not just even just the engineering part of it, the design, but also the bigger picture. I don't have an answer for you of like what happens in that situation where it's hit one or hit another. But I do know that there are some people who are
使这更安全。自动驾驶汽车呢？我的意思是，你如何开发一种自动驾驶汽车，让人们坐在那里并放弃控制权，或者他们是否必须有一点控制权才能感到舒适？汽车如何围绕“我撞那个桥台还是撞那个孩子”做出决定？是的，这是自动驾驶汽车领域的一个热门话题。我个人不做那方面的研究。我认识做那方面研究的人。该领域有一个巨大的伦理考量，不仅仅是工程部分，设计，还有大局。我没有答案告诉你那种撞一个还是撞另一个的情况会发生什么。但我确实知道有些人
still uneasy about autonomous vehicles. One, for those kinds of reasons, because accidents, collisions still do happen with vehicles that are full of safety features like that. And there are other people, as you mentioned, who don't want to pursue autonomous vehicles because they love driving. I'm not one of those people. I do not love driving. So as a traffic researcher, I hate driving. And if I have to drive in a simulator one more time, I'm going to lose my mind. But I know people who love, love driving. And I honestly can't see them really wanting to give up full control. So part of the conversation in that area is at some point in the future when autonomous
仍然对自动驾驶汽车感到不安。第一，因为那些原因，因为事故、碰撞仍然会发生在充满这种安全功能的车辆上。还有其他人，正如你提到的，他们不想追求自动驾驶汽车，因为他们喜欢开车。我不是那些人中的一员。我不喜欢开车。所以作为一名交通研究人员，我讨厌开车。如果我必须再在模拟器中开车一次，我会疯掉的。但我认识喜欢、喜欢开车的人。我真的看不出他们真的想放弃完全控制权。所以该领域对话的一部分是，在未来的某个时候，当自动驾驶
vehicles are everywhere, I guess. I don't know what that future is. But do you allow people to take control? Do you still allow vehicles that don't have autonomous control? So that's a challenging conversation in that area of research because some people would love to have it full autonomous because I think the assumption is that it is full safety. But again, it's not full safety. Maybe safer, but not full safety. There were news articles during and just after the pandemic about how COVID lockdowns made driver behavior worse. Did that actually happen? Is there data to show that?
汽车无处不在时，我想。我不知道那个未来是什么。但你允许人们控制吗？你仍然允许没有自动控制的车辆吗？所以这是该研究领域的一个具有挑战性的对话，因为有些人会喜欢拥有完全自动驾驶，因为我认为假设是它是完全安全的。但同样，它不是完全安全的。也许更安全，但不是完全安全。在疫情期间和之后，有新闻文章报道说新冠封锁使驾驶员行为变得更糟。这真的发生了吗？有数据证明吗？
Yes and no. I mean, during COVID, when there weren't a whole lot of vehicles on the road, there were plenty of media reports of people doing just absolutely crazy things on the road, like driving 180 kilometers an hour on a 100 kilometer an hour road. I mean, that's an insane speed because there's no other vehicles around. I think people were pushing the boundaries. but I think the average person didn't drive because of the lockdown. And after the lockdown, did people forget how to drive? Like, I had a reporter contact me and asked me about, like, did people forget everything?
有，也没有。我的意思是，在新冠期间，当路上没有太多车辆时，有很多媒体报道人们在路上做着绝对疯狂的事情，比如在100公里限速的路上开到180公里。我的意思是，那是一个疯狂的速度，因为周围没有其他车辆。我认为人们在突破界限。但我认为普通人因为封锁而没有开车。而在封锁之后，人们忘记了怎么开车吗？比如，有一个记者联系我，问我人们是否忘记了一切？
Like, people didn't forget how to drive. That skill base was still there. But I think in some ways, what happened is perhaps people forgot some of that transactional stuff. Maybe they forgot just how frustrating it was. perhaps they forgot how stressful some of the things were. And I think immediately after, there is some evidence where people just found it intolerable in some ways, where they had a return of stress that they hadn't had in a long time. And so for them, perceptually, they just saw that as this over-the-top thing,
就像，人们没有忘记怎么开车。那个技能基础仍然存在。但我认为在某些方面，发生的事情是也许人们忘记了一些交易性的东西。也许他们忘记了它有多令人沮丧。也许他们忘记了某些事情有多大的压力。而且我认为在之后立即，有一些证据表明人们在某些方面觉得它无法忍受，他们重新获得了很长一段时间没有的压力。所以对他们来说，在感知上，他们只是把它看作是这种过分的事情，
that there was this return of something that was so noxious for them that they had, to try to do something to recover from it. So you did hear, especially anecdotally, stories of people like, there's so many people out there honking at me. There are so many people tailgating me. There's so many people cutting me off. So again, I don't think it's that they forgot how to drive. It's just that there's this maybe rebound thing where it's just suddenly so new again. And in a magnitude that they had forgotten happened in their regular commutes. So I have to talk to you about the zipper merge. I know you've done some media interviews over the years about that. And I'm wondering, first of all, what's a zipper merge and why do people find them so stressful and controversial?
有一种他们很久没有经历过的有害事物的回归。所以你确实听到了，特别是轶事，人们的故事说：“外面有这么多人对我按喇叭。有这么多人跟车太近。有这么多人切入我的车道。”所以同样，我不认为他们忘记了怎么开车。只是可能有这种反弹，它突然又变得如此新鲜。而且程度之大，他们已经忘记了在他们的日常通勤中发生过。所以我必须和你谈谈拉链式合并（zipper merge）。我知道你多年来做过一些关于这个的媒体采访。我想知道，首先，什么是拉链式合并，为什么人们觉得它们如此有压力和争议？
In its simplest form, zipper merges, if you have two lanes that are supposed to come together as one lane, legitimately, it's probably not so much for a regular disappearing lane. They often talk about it in construction zones and things like that, where you typically have two lanes that have to become one lane. So the zipper is, each lane should take a turn. And in concept, you want people to stay in both lanes. And that actually helps the traffic move more quickly, rather than somebody a mile and a half down the road trying to force their way and just, just, you know, they see that there's that sign that says, oh, the right lane ends. And so they panic and they try to get over and they jam their way in. And what it does is it forces the
以最简单的形式，拉链式合并，如果你有两条应该合并为一条车道的车道，合法地，它可能对于一条普通的消失车道来说不是那么多。他们经常在施工区之类的地方谈论它，在那里你通常有两条必须变成一条车道的车道。所以拉链是，每条车道应该轮流。在概念上，你希望人们留在两条车道上。这实际上有助于交通移动得更快，而不是有人在路上一英里半的地方试图强行进入，只是，只是，你知道，他们看到那个标志说，“哦，右车道结束了。”所以他们惊慌失措，试图换道，他们强行挤进去。它所做的是迫使
people in that other lane to slam on their brakes or whatever and then they get ticked off. But again, in concept, if you stay in the two lanes and then everybody just takes a turn, it really runs smoothly and both of those lanes move fairly quickly. The reason why people hate it and there are people who really push back on this. And you can go on YouTube and there are people who will do little videos about how they block that jerk in that other lane from from getting in see people don't recognize that if they zipper it flows really well and they don't want somebody taking that space and like look i stayed in this lane and you're trying to break the rules yeah right so they see it as rule breaking even though it's
另一条车道上的人猛踩刹车之类的，然后他们就生气了。但同样，在概念上，如果你留在两条车道上，然后每个人都轮流，它确实运行得很顺畅，这两条车道移动得相当快。人们讨厌它的原因，而且确实有人真的反对这一点。你可以去YouTube，有人会制作小视频，关于他们如何阻止那个在另一条车道上的混蛋进入，看，人们没有意识到如果他们拉链式合并，它流动得非常好，他们不想让别人占据那个空间，就像“看，我留在这条车道上，而你试图违反规则。”是的，对吧？所以他们把它视为违规，即使它
not rule breaking so i think people just not used to do it and i think they're so accustomed to that that pattern of, I followed the rule, you didn't, you should suffer, not me. And if you cut in front of me, that means I take longer to get to my location. And so you're slowing me down further. And it creates frustration. It creates anger. And now somebody's trying to force their way in. And one of the reasons why people try to get over earlier is because they don't want to face that interaction, that uncomfortable interaction. of trying to get in and nobody will let them in and they get stuck there on that, that island, right?
不是违规。所以我认为人们只是不习惯这样做，而且我认为他们太习惯于那种模式了，“我遵守了规则，你没有，你应该受苦，而不是我。”如果你切入我前面，这意味着我到达目的地的时间更长。所以你进一步减慢了我的速度。它造成了挫败感。它造成了愤怒。现在有人试图强行进入。人们试图更早换道的原因之一是因为他们不想面对那种互动，那种不舒服的互动。试图进入，没有人会让他们进入，他们被困在那里，在那座岛上，对吧？
That disappearing lane island where you might, I don't know, you have your mail forwarded you could be there so long. Now, you were quoted in a recent New York Times article about noise cameras, these noise sensitive cameras that are supposed to catch and ticket people for excessive honking, which is illegal in New York City, I know. Why do people honk when they don't need to? think that noise cameras could be an effective way to get them to stop? Yeah. Why do people do stuff in traffic when they, when they, when they shouldn't?
那座消失的车道岛，你可能，我不知道，你把邮件转发了，你可能会在那里待很长时间。现在，你在最近的一篇《纽约时报》文章中被引用，关于噪音摄像头，这些噪音敏感摄像头应该捕捉并对过度按喇叭的人开罚单，我知道这在纽约市是违法的。为什么人们在不需要的时候按喇叭？认为噪音摄像头可能是让他们停止的有效方法吗？是的。为什么人们在交通中做他们不应该做的事情？
If I had the answer for that, I'd have a hundred books. Yeah, that honestly, that that really is one of the things that the social psychologist in me is still captivated by. Why do people do what they shouldn't do. And again, I think a lot of this comes back to the culture part. The reason why somewhere like New York City has so much honging is because people do it. I know that sounds oversimplified, but that really is. People honk because people honk. And it becomes an acceptable thing. And if there's no real consequence for it, so that the noise cameras are, I think it can be effective. But in order for something to be effective as a, quote, punishment for something, it has to be perceived as real. And if it's not being used and if it's not being really enforced, then it just doesn't enter people's consciousness as a reason to stop.
如果我有答案，我早就写了一百本书了。是的，老实说，这确实是我作为社会心理学家仍然着迷的事情之一。为什么人们会做他们不该做的事？再说一次，我认为这很大程度上归结于文化因素。像纽约市这样鸣笛声如此之多的原因，是因为人们都在这样做。我知道这听起来过于简单化，但事实确实如此。人们鸣笛是因为别人也在鸣笛。这成了一种可以接受的行为。如果对此没有真正的后果，那么我认为噪音摄像头可能会有效。但要使某种东西作为一种所谓的“惩罚”有效，它必须被视为是真实的。如果它没有被使用，也没有被真正执行，那么它就不会进入人们的意识，成为停止鸣笛的理由。
And horn honking really is one of these things that we've adapted in that traffic environment for expressing our frustration. We want to release it. and if somebody honks at you, then you honk back. It really does have a potential, though, to escalate to something much more dramatic because oftentimes these more extreme, quote, road rage things are the violent things often start with something simple like being honked at or somebody cutting into the lane in a zipper merge where they shouldn't have. Because it all becomes perceptual.
汽车鸣笛确实是我们为了表达挫败感而在交通环境中适应的一种方式。我们想要释放压力，如果有人对你鸣笛，你就会鸣笛回应。然而，这确实有可能升级为更戏剧性的事件，因为通常这些更极端的所谓“路怒”暴力事件，往往始于简单的行为，比如被鸣笛，或者有人在拉链式汇入时强行加塞。因为这一切都变成了感知问题。
People get upset that other people are doing things that they don't want them to do where they feel threatened or they feel aroused or they feel anger and they've got to express it some way. So horn honking can be an expression of aggression and it's fairly universal in some ways. Again, I just came back from another country where there's good bit of horn honking where people do it to signal, but people also do it as that expression of, you know, we're in an environment, we're in that vehicle and they can't see us. And while in some ways we talk about that as escalating the aggression potential. In another way, when you think about it, if you're in a supermarket lane and somebody cuts in front of you, they can see your angry expression. They can see that
人们因为别人做了他们不希望别人做的事而感到不安，或者感到受到威胁、被激怒或愤怒，他们必须以某种方式表达出来。因此，鸣笛可以是一种攻击性的表达，在某些方面它是相当普遍的。再说一次，我刚从另一个国家回来，那里鸣笛声也很多，人们鸣笛是为了发出信号，但人们也把它作为一种表达方式，你知道，我们身处那种环境中，在车里，别人看不见我们。虽然在某种程度上我们谈论这会升级攻击潜力，但从另一个角度想，如果你在超市排队，有人插队，他们能看到你愤怒的表情。他们能看到
they've made you upset. But in the traffic environment, they can't. And so we really need that other person to know that we're upset. And the most convenient way to do that is honk the horn. I mean, we could lean out the car and yell at them, but I'm sure that happens. Some of us do. that too. You know, not to dwell on New York particularly, but there's been controversy there because they've been trying to agree around limiting how much traffic can be in sort of the core part of the city and charging people, escalating amounts of money to drive in those areas. And that's created a great deal of controversy in the city. They were going to implement it and then the governor pulled back, how effective are programs like that where you really limit whether people can drive in the core
他们让你不高兴了。但在交通环境中，他们看不到。所以我们确实需要让对方知道我们不高兴。最方便的方法就是按喇叭。我的意思是，我们可以探出车窗对他们大喊大叫，但我相信这种情况确实会发生。我们有些人也会那样做。你知道，不是特别针对纽约，但那里一直存在争议，因为他们一直在试图就限制城市核心区域的交通流量达成一致，并对在这些区域驾驶的人收取不断增加的费用。这在城市中引起了很大的争议。他们本打算实施，但州长退缩了，像这样真正限制人们是否可以在核心区域驾驶的项目有多有效？
part of a big city? Yeah, and there is precedent in other big, big cities. But again, I'll go back to something is only effective as enforcement if it's perceived as real. So unless there is a mechanism where somebody's going to prevent or penalize people for breaking that rule, then there will be rule breakers. So what's on the horizon? What are some of the, what are the next big research questions that you want to answer? A lot of my more current thoughts really revolve around this personal space issue. I think it's a part of who we are as drivers that we don't really talk about a lot,
在大城市里，这在其他大城市是有先例的。但再说一次，我还是要回到这一点：只有当执法被认为是真实的时候，它才有效。所以，除非有一种机制可以阻止或惩罚违反规则的人，否则就会有违规者。那么未来会怎样？你想要回答的下一个重大研究问题是什么？我目前很多想法确实围绕着个人空间问题。我认为这是我们作为驾驶员的一部分，但我们并没有真正深入讨论过，
these unseen things that we transport with us. I mean, I've done a lot in terms of how we care. things from other environments. And our personal space is something that's always there with us. But it varies and it's adaptable to different environments. And again, this is one of the things that's really captivated me about the traffic environment is that people generally don't think about how impactful it is on their lives. You've got to get to work somehow. You've got to get home somehow. And we accept that there's kind of this spillover. And you mentioned spillover earlier.
这些我们随身携带的看不见的东西。我的意思是，我在我们如何携带东西从其他环境进入交通环境方面做了很多研究。我们的个人空间是始终伴随着我们的。但它会根据不同的环境而变化和调整。再说一次，这是让我对交通环境真正着迷的事情之一，因为人们通常不会考虑它对他们的生活有多大影响。你总得想办法去上班。你总得想办法回家。我们接受了这种溢出效应。你刚才提到了溢出效应。
There's this spillover that happens between work and home. And so if you have a really bad day at home, you bring it to work. If you have a really bad day at work, you bring it home. But people forget that you've got to get to those other environments somehow. We have personal space at work. And I think people will recognize that that, you know, if I'm sitting in my desk and somebody comes too close to me, then I might do something to protect myself from that. And maybe in the workplace environment, it's fairly easy to just kind of back off or something like that. Or you visualize that so that they can see.
工作和家庭之间确实存在这种溢出效应。所以如果你在家里度过了糟糕的一天，你会把它带到工作中。如果你在工作中度过了糟糕的一天，你会把它带回家。但人们忘记了你必须以某种方式到达那些环境。我们在工作中有个人空间。我认为人们会意识到，如果我坐在办公桌前，有人靠我太近，我可能会采取一些行动来保护自己。也许在工作环境中，退后一步或类似的事情很容易做到。或者你可以通过视觉表现出来，让他们看到。
But in the traffic environment, you can't see the person. And there's much more at stake in violating that personal space. So I think there's a greater potential for us to be defensive of that space. But people generally don't use that language. In fact, traffic researchers generally don't use that language and don't talk about this. idea of bringing our personal space, that bubble of safety, if you will, into the traffic environment. So I would love to see more conversation within my discipline about that. And it's impact on the things that I do research on, which of course are most important, right? Because
但在交通环境中，你看不见对方。侵犯个人空间的风险要大得多。所以我认为我们更有可能去捍卫那个空间。但人们通常不会使用这种语言。事实上，交通研究人员通常也不会使用这种语言，也不会谈论这种将我们的个人空间——或者说安全气泡——带入交通环境的想法。所以我很乐意看到我的学科内对此进行更多的讨论。以及它对我所研究的事物的影响，当然这些是最重要的，对吧？因为
those are the things I'm interested in is how it impacts our stress, how it impacts our aggression, because those are some of the things that we do find are being transported into the next environment, how it influences your work performance and your work mood and your work interactions and your home life. Well, Dr. Hennessy, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Yeah, I'm glad to be part of this. I am always happy to talk about traffic. It's something that I think about a lot. And I think it's something that a lot of people are really keenly interested in. And I love being able to put that scientific spin on that conversation. So thanks for having me.
这些是我感兴趣的事情，即它如何影响我们的压力，如何影响我们的攻击性，因为这些是我们发现会被带入下一个环境的事情，它如何影响你的工作表现、工作情绪、工作互动和家庭生活。好的，亨内西博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。这真的很有趣。是的，我很高兴能参与其中。我总是很乐意谈论交通问题。这是我经常思考的事情。而且我认为这是很多人都非常感兴趣的事情。我很高兴能为这种对话注入科学的视角。所以谢谢你邀请我。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Winerman 制作。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。放松一下，让 Ralph's 的配送服务为您处理本周的杂货采购吧。
We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们只从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着我们打包好，并在短短 30 分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您订购的商品。新鲜杂货，随心所欲，尽在 Ralph's 配送和自提服务。现在，您的首次配送或自提订单可节省 20 美元。Ralph's，为每个人提供新鲜。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。